I've been telling you this week that
some prominent Republican players are
turning on Donald Trump not over the
Ukraine fiasco mind you but over the
Syria and Kurd fiasco that we've been
talking about and as we covered earlier
this week Donald Trump has pulled troops
from northern Syria despite everyone
from many Republicans all the way to
Noam Chomsky agreeing that this is a
very bad idea to do that turkey will
immediately attack the Kurds if Donald
Trump does that Trump did it and
immediately Turkey attacked Kurdish
forces in northern Syria and now you've
got Moscow Mitch McConnell who's not
pleased you've got loony Lindsey Graham
who's not pleased and loony Lindsey is
making his displeasure known but we need
to do the political analysis as well
here very rarely does Looney Lindsey go
against Donald Trump in a serious manner
and here he is doing it tweeting
yesterday quote pray for our Kurdish
allies who have been shamelessly
abandoned by the Trump administration
this move ensures the re-emergence of
Isis now loony Lindsey happens to be
right on this particular issue narrowly
interpreted remember when Lindsey Graham
said that Republicans would get
destroyed if they nominated Trump this
was back in 2016 when Lindsey tweeted if
we nominate Trump we will get destroyed
and we will deserve it well he happened
to be wrong Donald Trump won but just a
reminder that Lindsey Graham is merely a
guy who calculates the political space
that he is staking out so while Lindsey
Graham happens to be correct about the
Kurds and Trump's decision to abandon
them he's found something to critically
criticize Donald Trump over but remember
that just months ago at the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings loonie Lindsey
delivered what is maybe the most
unhinged confirmation hearing speech
that I have ever seen from a senator on
these confirmation hearing panels do you
remember this and please I'm going to
give you a few moments get the kids out
of the room
is not what I would want my children
seeing if I had children loony Lindsay
and maybe the most unhinged confirmation
hearing speech in the history of
American politics if you wanted an FBI
investigation you could have come to us
what you want to do is destroy this
guy's life hold this seat open and hope
you win in 2020 you said that not me
you've got nothing to apologize for when
you see soda mire and cake and tell them
that Lindsay said all because I voted
for them I would never do to them what
you've done to this guy this is the most
unethical sham since I've been in
politics and if you really wanted to
know the truth you sure as hell wouldn't
have done what you've done to this guy
are you a gang rapist
no there's a guy who's making sense
right so listen I I have no praise for
Graham he is a flip-flopper put my
finger to the wind and see what will get
me some kind of attention type of guy he
will sometimes come to conclusions that
sound logical or they sound remotely
sane and then the next day he will take
some outrageous position that is the
exact opposite of logical insane and
case in point yesterday Lindsey Graham
attacks Donald Trump because clearly
Donald Trump's actions are wrong to him
and then he's at the same time I mean
lit the day before he was fighting
against the constitutional enshrined by
the law impeachment inquiry into Donald
Trump he's a disgrace and in fact as I
mentioned earlier in the show this may
all be calculated in order to either
distract from the impeachment inquiry to
set himself up to claim and partiality
on the impeachment inquiry because there
could be a broader plan here Trump
doesn't have the ability to do non
concrete multi-dimensional thinking from
can't do it Lindsey Graham is capable of
that and so there may be a calculation
here that Lindsey Graham is saying
listen I want to oppose Trump's
impeachment as strongly as possible and
the way to do that without appearing
like a
mere reflexive partisan hack which he is
would be to criticize Trump somewhere
but then to come around and say listen
I've been as critical of Trump as the
next person when Trump abandoned the
Kurds I criticized him but the
impeachment inquiry is unconstitutional
and it must end I would not put it past
Lindsey Graham to be thinking in that
way and to be calculating along those
lines because in the end he's disgusting
and we'd be much better off if someone
could defeat him in South Carolina and
get him out of the Senate and he in the
end is still a participant in as
strongly as possibly maintaining the
trumpian status quo even though he says
he disagrees with Trump on this Lindsey
Graham's broader positioning as a
brown-nosing sycophant of Donald Trump's
who defends the idea of Trump as
president as anything other than a
national atrocity that is not changed
and until I see evidence that it has
changed lou.neil in Lindsey is just
doing what he always does which is
putting his finger to the wind figuring
out how he can make a statement or make
a political calculation that will get
him more attention that will get him
more airtime or time with the President
or time in the media or whatever that's
all that's going on here this weekend
okay we are doing a massive David Pakman
show membership drive it's gonna be a
one-day membership drive we haven't done
this for like a year we are blowing out
membership okay
massive massive membership discount if
you've been thinking about supporting
the program this weekend you will have
the best opportunity of the year to do
it at the lowest rate if you want to be
notified about this extraordinary
membership discount sign up for our
newsletter on our website david
pakman.com very clear spot there you can
get our newsletter this weekend you will
get an email and it will be a beautiful
thing for everybody who chooses to
participate let me know your thoughts
about loonie lindsay on twitter at d
Pakman while you're there follow the
show at david pakman show we'll take a
quick break very very much news to
discuss today with you do it cappucci
paid-for de Gracia Mila one of our
sponsors making the David Pakman show
possible is Babel the language learning
app and you'll get 25% off a
subscription to babble
when you click the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used babble
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on babble only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and use babble to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount of time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend babble to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to babble when you
click the link right underneath this
video